I am so fucking happy that people are having eyes on Mama Todd,
because let me tell you about my fucking experience with Mama Todd.
I don't think she's all that she's cracked up to be.
She does not give a fuck about people.
She is not some loving, caring person.
Some of you may remember me from this video
where I was annoyed
that I felt I was being disrespected as the mother of my children.
The people who knew me and know my story and understand everything
were like, oh, shit,
that's fucked up. People on the internet who didn't know shit about me
just entered in their own details
and let try to fucking light me on fire.
Mama taught was one of those fucking people.
And here's the thing.
Mental illness was another big creator on this app
that people were tagging him like,
this bitch is a fucking narc.
She's fucking narcissist. Oh,
my god, light her ass on fire.
People must have been doing the same thing to Mama Todd
because I was being so nasty to the stepmom.
Well, mental illness sent me a fucking DM and said, hey,
I'm getting tagged a lot in your videos.
What's going on? I literally gave him, like,
three sentences. He was like,
oh, that's triangulation.
Yeah, but I get it.
People are confused because of the way you're delivering the message,
you know, whatever.
Him and I are now friends.
Now we're friends. We're mutuals.
On the app Mama taught,
she fucking stitched my video and tried to call me out
that if somebody's ever giving your child love,
you better accept it.
And you're in the wrong for trying to push this woman away.
She didn't come and clarify any details.
One simple DM. She didn't give a little once
look over on my content
to maybe get a little better understanding of the situation,
because I'm so sorry. Isn't that how grooming of children happens?
They're really nice to them.
They shower them with gifts and kindness
so that they can then later hurt them?
I have every reason to want to.
And also, if you go back and watch that fucking video,
I'm not even mad that somebody's helping my child.
What I'm mad at is that somebody is robbing me of the opportunity
of being there with them. If this is a mother daughter thing,
where the fuck is the mom?
You're just the stepmom. Stop trying to step in the way.
Get the. You know what I mean?
That was my original point, anyway,
wasn't that? Oh,
I'm so mad somebody's giving my child love.
I'm mad that you're gonna try to scoop me out of this situation
for no fucking reason, and now I'm fucking pissed.
Do you know what I'm saying?
So, yeah,
I think Mama Tata is a fraud.
I think she's lame,
and I'm glad that people are seeing her for who she is.